[Música]
hola muy bienvenidos a la entrevista de
france 24 recientemente fue como merado
el día internacional de las víctimas de
desapariciones forzadas un conflicto que
atraviesa de una manera muy particular a
colombia' hablamos de un país con una
historia marcada en parte por supuesto
por la violencia del conflicto armado
protagonizado por guerrillas enfrentadas
a grupos paramilitares y fuerzas del
estado
hablamos de décadas de violaciones a los
derechos humanos que dejaron miles de
personas desaparecidas que todavía son
buscadas por sus familiares y también
por organizaciones y entidades estatales
una herida que continúa abierta pero
sobre la que afortunadamente muchísimas
personas están trabajando para reparar
especialmente tras la firma del acuerdo
de paz firmado entre el gobierno
colombiano y la extinta guerrilla de las
farc en el año 2016 por eso nos acompaña
en esta oportunidad luz marina monzón
cifuentes ella es directora de la unidad
de búsqueda de personas dadas por
desaparecidas en contexto y en razón del
conflicto armado colombiano es abogada
especializada en derecho penal y
criminología y lleva décadas
al conflicto de las desapariciones
forzadas luz marina son sin fuentes
muchísimas gracias por su presencia en
france 24
muchísimas gracias a santiago por esta
invitación y bueno la importancia de
recordar a los desaparecidos
absolutamente por eso el motivo de esta
entrevista no hay para tomar dimensión
del conflicto no y sobre todo para
nuestra audiencia internacional las
cifras varían según la fuente pero
cuántos desaparecidos se estima que hay
en colombia al día de hoy
y desaparecidos desaparecidos
forzadamente la cifra más aproximada
digo yo se ha establecido en colombia la
del centro nacional de memoria histórica
en el 2016 que habla de 86 mil personas
desaparecidas forzadamente durante el
conflicto armado
hablemos de buscar el concepto de buscar
en el imaginario colectivo muchas veces
se cree que se trata de buscar fosas
rastrear no de estar investigando en el
terreno pero se trata no desde la unidad
de una tarea muchísimo más amplia verdad
sobre todo porque en la unidad de
búsqueda de personas tienen un enfoque
humanitario no más que judicial
así es así de santiago y esto es muy muy
importante lo que están mencionando
porque buscar no es solamente abrir una
fosa porque de hecho podríamos encontrar
personas vivas a veces se olvida que la
búsqueda también puede ser con una
perspectiva y esa es la que tienen las
víctimas de esa esperanza de poder
encontrar a sus seres queridos vivos
entonces efectivamente la búsqueda de
los desaparecidos puede llevarnos a una
fosa pero también puede llevarnos a
encontrar una persona que sé que la
familia nunca volvió a saber de él pero
que se fue reclutado o que fue
secuestrado y que en esas condiciones
las posibilidades de encontrarlos vivos
que existen y entonces la búsqueda
principalmente de la recolección
organización de información que nos
permite establecer hipótesis de hallazgo
de los desaparecidos y la y con esto
termino el
la posibilidad de que se haga desde una
perspectiva humanitaria y extrajudicial
abre oportunidades muy grande de poder
encontrar esa información que nos
permita recobrar la huella que fue
borrada cuando la persona es
desaparecida ahora el período no durante
el cual han tenido lugar las
desapariciones forzadas es extenso a
vorsah aborda distintos escenarios
históricos y también por supuesto
geográficos cuáles son los lineamientos
generales del plan nacional de búsqueda
que llevan adelante
bueno esta es una una apuesta este de
estado diría yo o sea está a cargo de la
unidad de búsqueda pero es una apuesta
del estado en qué sentido en el sentido
de que el plan nacional aborda los
problemas estratégicos claves esenciales
para poder encontrar a los desaparecidos
y que han sido objeto de dificultades
para poder encontrar cuáles son esos
objetivos estratégicos es la búsqueda de
la información cómo se organiza cómo se
centraliza cómo se actualiza y se pone
disponible la información que nos
permite encontrar los desaparecidos
2 cómo se busca a los desaparecidos en
lugares de paradero por ejemplo los
cementerios por ejemplo las fosas
comunes por ejemplo los lugares de
información que podrían llevarnos a
encontrar una ruta de una persona viva
por ejemplo los servicios de salud
los servicios de auxilios que pueden
llevarnos a los registros de personas
que puedan haber sido objeto de trata y
que no no se sabe dónde está la persona
pero que pueda aparecer un reporte de
esta persona en algún registro de esta
naturaleza los registros y lo planteaban
las comunidades lgbt y los registros de
cambio de sexo clínicas informaciones de
clínicas nos ayudará a encontrar
información esos son lugares de
localización veía acá en colombia uno de
los lugares de localización que las
víctimas plantean son los ríos cómo se
va a buscar en los ríos porque muchas
personas saben que muchas personas
desaparecidas fueron asesinadas y luego
tiradas a los ríos entonces ese es otro
encuentro estratégico del plan nacional
y el tercer objetivo estratégico del
plan nacional o diciendo a la tarea de
que la unidad es un mecanismo de
justicia transicional que debe
contribuir a la reparación y a la verdad
de las víctimas
la participación como van a participar
las víctimas en este proceso de búsqueda
entonces el plan nacional y en estos
tres ejes estratégicos junto con un
capítulo étnico que es clave para poder
hacer la búsqueda en los territorios que
con las comunidades hablando de los
territorios no en colombia hay regiones
particularmente afectadas por el
conflicto de las desapariciones forzadas
que hacen que un territorio sea más
propenso a sufrir estas violaciones a
los derechos humanos
bueno que hacen la marginalidad la
distancia con el estado hay territorios
donde el estado no llega o la presencia
del estado es mínima o históricamente no
ha tenido una fortaleza está presente en
el territorio en las vías de
comunicación lo que a la persona les
cuesta mucho trabajo poder acceder a las
autoridades para su protección
el territorio es donde el conflicto
armado y todo lo asociado al conflicto
armado hacen más vulnerables las
comunidades comunidades étnicas han sido
muy muy afectadas por el conflicto
armado y con poca visibilidad de la
dimensión de esa de esas de esas
consecuencias del conflicto
creo que la existencia también de
actores de asociados al narcotráfico y
todo lo que se juega en el narcotráfico
son también aspectos que afectan y ponen
mayor vulnerabilidad a las comunidades
pero lamentablemente debo decir de
santiago que la desaparición forzada no
ha distinguido territorios la
desaparición forzada es una una
violación a derechos humanos que tenía
ocurrencia en todo el territorio
colombiano durante estas más de cinco
décadas de existencia del conflicto que
aún no se es
no marina un tema clave en la historia
colombiana tiene que ver con los falsos
positivos no algunos familiares de
desaparecidos forzadamente celebraron
recientemente la detención del ex
presidente álvaro uribe así reaccionaron
por ejemplo algunas de las madres de
soacha que son para nuestra audiencia
les contamos familiares de jóvenes de
esta región colombiana asesinados
presuntamente por el ejército durante la
administración de uribe los familiares
apuntan al conflicto al que hago
referencia de los 'falsos positivos'
como les decía al comienzo de la
pregunta un tema clave en la historia de
colombia pero desconocido por una parte
de la comunidad internacional por eso le
pido a usted una voz más que autorizada
no para explicarlo nos ayudaría a
comprenderlo un poco más de cerca con
muchísimo gusto santiago miren cuando
uno estudia la desaparición forzada uno
estudia una una imagen de la
desaparición y esa imagen donde los
agentes del estado ese es el histórico
de la desaparición forzada agentes del
estado
detienen a una persona borran su huella
no dan razones ni de su paradero ni de
la suerte de la persona y entonces la
familia empieza a buscarlos sin poder
encontrarlos porque justamente la
desaparición lo que hace es desaparecer
todo no solamente la persona sino la
huella de la misma desaparición ese es
el concepto histórico de la desaparición
forzada pero en colombia la dinámica del
conflicto armado ha llevado a de aaa
deterioros de los límites de lo que es
la confrontación y los deterioros del
conflicto que ha llevado a que agentes
del estado presuntamente hayan bueno en
algunos casos se ha determinado la
responsabilidad de gente del estado bajo
procesos de investigaciones penales bajo
la siguiente modalidad y es que en aras
de mostrar resultados de que se está
ganando la guerra de que hay resultados
que mandan el mensaje que se ha reducido
a las guerrillas
presentan resultados de bajas de esas
aparentes guerrillas y entonces
muchachos jóvenes pero no solamente
jóvenes personas mayores personas con
discapacidad personas con marginalidad
es económicas sociales fueron ofrecerles
a ellos se les ofreció un trabajo y eso
a través de reclutadores que se llevaron
a estas personas supuestamente bajo el
la expectativa y la esperanza de tener
un trabajo y luego fueron asesinados y
fueron vestidos de camuflado para
mostrarlos como miembros de la guerrilla
que habían sido de va eso es lo que se
ha conocido como 'falso positivo' yo
honestamente creo que esto tiene un
nombre bajo el derecho internacional de
los derechos humanos que son ejecuciones
arbitrarias y eso es lo que ha ocurrido
acá
desgraciadamente durante una etapa del
conflicto del deterioro de la
degradación del conflicto armado en este
país
luz marina monzón cifuentes muchísimas
gracias por su presencia en la
entrevista de france 24 ha sido
realmente un placer dialogar con usted
muchísimas gracias santiago por favor a
usted a nuestra audiencia le invitamos a
continuar informándose en el resto de
nuestra programación y les recordamos
que pueden volver a ver esta entrevista
y muchas otras más en nuestra página web
france24 puntocom
[Música]
bien